there is thomas darwin eshelman from
carlsbad california former second round
pick by the astros back in 2015 out of
cal state fullerton
making his tenth appearance it is his
first start he leads this team and wins
with three wins 3.96 era
working 25 innings 11 punch-outs eight
walks opponents hitting just 213 off
thomas escherman look at ozzy scoop that
right off the dirt
on the first pitch he's chugging for two
ozzy is on his way close play and in
time ozzy albees gets in ahead of the
throw
wow what a slide here if he's safe
because that throw beat him
but ozzy went to the inside of the bag
and then was able to hang on and
couldn't see where he was going
swim move
great call by the umpire and freddie
freeman's the hitter
trying to extend a 30 game on base
streak to 31
in game two tonight
driven toward right field that ball is
hammered that ball is high it is off the
wall that's a base hit that'll score
ozzie freddie freeman trades places at
second the braves have two doubles and
their first run here in the third inning
make it 31 in a row on base for the
braves first baseman his 45th rbi
88 89 mile an hour fastball and bat
shatter all he had left was the handle
no balls in his strike
and a swing and a drive new bat and that
baby is long gone
adam duvall golfs a solo home run out at
oriole park at camden yards and the
braves extend their lead it's two to
nothing
dropped the bat head and golfed it out
of here 20 rows deep that's how you
break in a new one you get a change up
in boy schulman knew it didn't he and
back to first is riley two men are out
and back to the top we go and ronald
acuna junior two on count
and ronald apparently checked his swing
that's to this inning that didn't go
their way now brandon hyde's gonna come
out and talk with you know pirate first
base and he's saying there's three of
them can't argue balls and strikes and
bill welky's telling brandon hyde
hit the road
i tell you when he swung i actually
thought he went but now looking at the
replay i do believe he held we didn't
see that part hyde was ejected after he
erupted on the check swing
so freddie gonzalez will take over the
lineup card for the orioles
in the atlanta fourth three balls in a
strike
[Applause]
and acuna drops his bat takes a walk and
the ending continues with freddie
freeman
in the air to center mullins puts it
away
but the braves get a run on the duvall
home run
joshua jachowski on for his second
inning with the kunya freeman and ozuna
looking for a little insurance around a
low for three with a walk
full count pitch
and acuna takes ball four high he walks
for
the second time freddie has two more
hits tonight an rbi double in the third
a seventh inning single ronald's getting
a nice lead yep not going though
and freddie smokes that to right center
field that's down ronald streaking
around second on his way to third over
quickly is
mullins ronald's rolling around third
throw to the plate is gonna be late and
all the way around a third is freddie
freeman a big insurance run
ronald acuna jr scores from first and
the braves lead three-nothing
that's what i was talking about that's
how ronald can beat you even without
putting the ball in play and that ball
didn't even get all the way into the gap
against the wall
man was that fast
man was that fun great slide so it's
three nothing atlanta freeman with
another double he takes third on the
throw a three hit night now let's get
another ozuna has reached base twice
smoked toward left freddy can crawl home
it's four nothing atlanta
44th rbi for ozuna and the braves are
putting this away in the ninth
now darnold shoots one the other way
ozuna's thinking about going to third he
rounds second he's going to make it
without a throw all of a sudden in the
ninth inning the braves are first and
third in the orioles to death
still nobody out two more hits for
travis darno and 13 for the braves
tonight so it's the 12th game this year
for the braves with 13 hits or more
swanson's one for four
breaking ball hanger and a shot to left
hayes makes the catch ozuna tags he's
coming to the plate he's gonna score
standing up it's five nothing give
dansby his 27th rbi good abc baseball by
the braves
sends up iglesias
chops this one to third
reilly
gets the out at first orioles pick up
their first run
as iglesias with his 20th rbi of the
year but now down to your final out
and stewart has a 1-1 count with the
bases empty the pitch
and that is to second ozzie good play
settles his feet throws to first and
what a rebound for atlanta after falling
14-1 last night jeff they came back and
played a clean crisp game to trim their
magic number to 9-5-1 the final score